I wrote it, I sent it, I'm ****d
- My ex boyfriend and I,
the breakup itself
probably took longer
than the actual
relationship lasted.
At one point, he was like,
"I need a little bit of space,"
and I was like,
"You got it, babe."
And instead of doing that,
I immediately sent him
the most heinous email
that I have ever written
in my entire life.
I chose to write it
while it was raining,
so that I could look outside
at the rain while I cried.
Here are a few highlights
from that email.
(classical music)
"If I ever made you
feel like you were less
"than the most important
thing in my life, I'm sorry.
"And in a month, when we
meet up in Union Square,
"I hope you will
hold me in your arms
"and we can go back to being
what we were meant to be.
"Do you remember the night
you said you would die for me?
"I don't want you to do that.
"I just want you to love me."
Oh my god, why?
(exhales)
And I ended it with a quote
from a Garth Brooks song,
even though neither of us
listen to Garth Brooks' music.
I went nuts.
It was this really long,
super intense email.
He responded to it like
three or four days later,
and literally just said,
"Thank you."
That bitch just said
thank you, that's it.
Thank you?
Double f*** yous.
It was the most
embarrassing thing
that I have ever done.
The only good thing
that came out of that
is when he sent
me back the email
that said thank you,
I was immediately
over that little turd.
Pro tip,
if he asks for space,
maybe don't be crazy.